hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
folge minecraft mai in der heutigen
folge sind wir im netz noch immer wieder
letzten volk und ihr volles max ja wir
haben jetzt noch ein paar level weiter
gefahren es ist die vorletzte folge
uns tut es wahrscheinlich genauso im
herzen weh ihr euch die vorletzte folge
meine damen und herren im wahrsten sinne
des wortes zu enden weil wir nächste
folge ins entgehen werden ja genau das
heißt heute schon auf die nächste folge
da werden wir ins entgehen wir werden
dem ganzen projekt nochmal so das ganze
projekt ein bisschen revue passieren
lassen und so weiter aber für diese
folge haben natürlich wieder eine
challenge und zwar haben wir die speed
challenge taffe haben ich und max hat ja
auch gerade so ein bisschen das papier
geholt haben das hier schon liegen wir
haben den edding und wir werden es jetzt
einfach so machen dass wir uns einen
timer stellen und alle zwei minuten
müssen wir das was wir gerade in
minecraft sehen aufmalen auf ein blatt
papier
ja das machen wir jetzt einfach mal dann
lasst uns ab in das portal springen ja
es ist jetzt schon hart wird zwar noch
zwei diamanten gefunden also ich habe in
der never rüstung oder sind leute mit
gekommen
ich habe in der rüstung in der festung
habe ich zwei diamanten gefunden haben
so alles hingekriegt
jetzt kommen wir diese scheiß wie ich
also ich hab es noch zwei diamanten
gefunden das heißt wenn jetzt insgesamt
drei diamanten dafür brauchen wir aber
einen für den tisch das heißt bei
diamanten da kann sich einen diamant
schwert machen fürs ende aber wir werden
wahrscheinlich eh besser die dinge
zusammenlegen
wir geben uns wirklich mühe dass wir
gewinnen also dass wir den den ender
drachen besiegen wir haben zwar nur
eisen rüstung und es wird extrem schwer
aber wir versuchen unser das also ich
weiß nie wahrscheinlich verrecken wir
einfach direkt aber ich würde erstmal
sagen wir machen jetzt in wir machen
genau jetzt einen stopp bleibt bestehen
und jetzt malen wir das was wir jetzt
gerade gesehen haben auf und wir sehen
uns dann sofort wieder wenn wir das
ausgemalt haben innerhalb von 30
sekunden oder so
ok max die 30 sekunden sind um mainz ist
noch nicht ganz fertig geworden 32
ihr könnt ja gerade war vergleichen von
dem was ich sehe
das heißt jetzt könnt ihr quasi sehen
was max sieht so fährt er erst in gut
gezeichnet hat ich erkläre mir ein
bisschen das mein schwert an der seite
dann ist luca und so tür und es ist aber
es ist grässlich ich probier beim
nächsten mal mit einem edding zu malen
aber es ist einfach schrecklich ich kann
so schlecht nein ich bin mal gespannt
wer von uns beiden am ende besser gemalt
hat eigentlich ihr könnt ja theoretisch
mal in die kommentare schreiben welches
bild die besser findet also in den
nächsten zwei drei minuten müssen wir
gleich wieder ein bild malen aber bis
dahin wollten wir mal ebenen enchantment
table machen jagd und mir ist
aufgefallen dass die in der folge bei
max sowie die diamanten gefunden haben
oder nicht das war auch meine folge da
haben wir gesagt dass wir nur einen
diamanten brauchen für den champion
table wir brauchen allerdings zwei das
heißt wir können uns glücklich schätzen
dass wir jetzt im nenner noch zwei
gefunden haben weißt du wie man so einen
enchantment table baut ja weißt du was
du es ja okay dann geht mir einfach die
materialien sind in der kiste hier
ich habe jedoch nicht mehr kannst du mal
schauen ob du eine spinne findet wir
haben noch keine bögen das wäre perfekt
denn wenn wir einen spieler finden dass
wir ohne schäden aufgefallen ich
dummkopf ein paar sekunden später habe
ich auch den shader drin wieder meine
damen und herren ihr seht schon ist
alles ein bisschen düsterer das ist mir
das aufgefallen also tut mir leid da
setzt die ersten 12 minuten vielleicht
ohne schilder waren wie gesagt wir
nehmen gerade die ganzen folgen im
voraus auf weil wir in urlaub fahren max
und ich und es ist einfach erleben wir
sind so müde aber wir machen alles nur
für euch damit minecraft mortier passen
fertig wird wir brauchen noch ist trinkt
hier müssen uns ja bögen machen dass wir
gegen ende brach mit bögen kämpfen kann
ja oder an das nach unten gehen spinnen
ja gut dass wir nicht die nacht verpasst
haben hier schon eine spinne
ich habe schon jetzt keinen string
gedroppt
hier läuft auch keine anlagen keine
spinne hast du spinnen bei mir leute nur
zombies und so die ganze zeit hin auch
noch keine gerade noch bei mir immer
unter die bäume
irgendwie sind die spinnen nicht so
vertreten bei uns ist mir auch schon
aufgefallen ich hab noch gar keinen
string hier ist aber gerade im krieg und
ich will nicht dass er unsere welt
kaputt macht als ich vor allem alles neu
aufgebaut habe das gute bei den shader
ist halt das spinnen die leuchten mit
ihren augen das heißt ich werde mich
jetzt mal einfach hier vom podest
stellen und mal schauen ob ich irgendwo
spinnen augen sehe aber ich sehe da
hinten ist nun creeper spinnen sehe ich
keine da oben ist auch noch ein creeper
darunter dahin ist und später gerade neu
gespannt
[Applaus]
die teenager und string ich hab string
und feile bisschen aber jetzt auch nicht
ultra viel max also ich weiß nicht ob
das alles reicht was was wir überhaupt
machen aber ich mein okay wir haben
jetzt zehn folgen für das alles
gebraucht das heißt es kann uns glaube
ich keiner übel nehmen wobei es können
uns wahrscheinlich die ganz harten frost
schon über ihr übelnehmen aber wirklich
also wir sind immer noch kran und
konkreter wir sind die übelsten profis
wächst also es ist ja ein fan projekt
unten
deshalb waren ja auch die tester ich bin
mir eigentlich sicher dass das für jeden
was dabei war auch mit change ist oder
was auch immer oder wegen minecraft
hoffe einfach dass es euch gefallen hat
das projekt bisher aber wir wollen noch
nicht so reden hatte dass das andere
erst morgen ist das genau morgen kommt
das ende auf max kanal wir sind hier
gerade noch ein monster jagten also
zumindest bei mir sind gerade überall
knoch creeper zombies und so ich habe
auf jeden fall meine menge an strings
also ich habe
so sehe ich denn hier strings wie sehen
die denn aus ich habe ich die nicht
aufgenommen weil ich dachte gerade ich
hätte zwei studierte so einfach nur zwei
strings kunden warte mal ich erwarte
hier war hat sich noch mehr ich habe ich
hab die aufgehoben hätte ich aber noch
mehr
also ich hab zwei stück aufgehoben 40
hatte ich glück haben wir alles wir
haben vier strings nur aber sonst ist es
wohl wir halt nur falls off screen noch
welche eine debatte wie wir müssen jetzt
auch eben die obwohl verzaubern wir auch
verdammt ist das da oben eine spinne ist
nun rose können nicht mehr einfach ein
paar spenden kommen die ganze zeit so
viele videos ich sehe was weise scheinen
dann bild malen sich gerade bleibt ein
auto stehen
ständig muss die töten ja dann töte sie
eben aber ich fange schon mal an zu
malen macht machen los mal zieht das
scheiße aus bei mir gerade
warum weil ich eigentlich mit wir haben
bisher alle change ist so gemacht dass
nur 13 21 es ist so presse ich gebe mich
ich mich auch weil da ich mich auch ist
er ist einfach bitte an gott ey leute
diese bilder die wir malen
die verkaufen sich bei 400 millionen
likes für drei millionen euro bei ebay
wenn die 400 millionen leichte jetzt
nicht schafft dann seid ihr anscheinend
etwas so magst du bist du denn wollen
wir jetzt mal ein paar zaubern wir
können uns jetzt echt endgültig
vorbereiten
leute ihr könnt eigentlich auch jetzt
schon mal bei luca in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr glaubt dass wir im
end den ender drachen besiegen werden
und somit unser projekt ziel erreichten
dann schreibt jetzt allemal and in die
kommentare einfach nur in alle and in
die kommentare wenn ihr denkt dass wir
schaffen können ich schreibe es nicht in
die kommentare
ich weiß läuft ja auch nicht erhöht habe
aber immer noch mit nichts orten einfach
einschreiben ich finde wir am echten
eine so gute leistung hier abgezielt
unser haus sieht schön aus
wir sind einigermaßen ausgerüstet und
insgesamt ist es eigentlich für also ich
bin zufrieden muss ich sagen das ist
doch nicht die letzte folge das werden
wir der nächsten folge morgen alles
revue passieren lassen sage ich mal so
ein bisschen aber ich bin ehrlich gesagt
auch zufrieden ich bin doch gerade
wieder dabei das haus noch ein bisschen
schöner zu bauen mit seinem weg und so
was alles weil es halt einfach spaß
macht also ich weiß nicht ich habe keine
lust ist ja alles ist mir irgendwie
wieder herzugeben oder so das macht
schon spaß aber apropos hergeben
wahrscheinlich wird es für euch ein
download geben wir aber sagen ich wollte
es ganz noch sagen vielleicht aber
müssen wir hinkriegen mit mit den leuten
von prepaid horster die uns den server
gegeben haben ich denke das sollte kein
problem sein aber wohl wieder machen
brauchen wie love is haben wir noch
besser wäre es wenn wir noch ein
bisschen eisen hätten dass wir die
sachen reparieren können 720 eisen und
dann machst du einfach drei in die
untere reihe eins in die mitte und unten
die drei dem amboss perfekt platziert
immer dahin die rüstungsteile packen wir
jetzt alle im versorgungs tisch und
verzaubern sie hast du musst dir
reinlegen ja habe ich habe schon 1 und
fehlerfall 2 auf meinen
du kannst es immer wieder rein und raus
tun falls du eine andere versorgung ja
alles gut also ich denke ich denke wir
werden das schaffen moment als ich bin
eigentlich recht zuversichtlich wir
machen uns noch schwerter zusätzliche
schwerter haben noch diamanten dafür
nenne mir leider nicht aber es nicht so
schlimm falls ihr euch wundert wie wir
ins entkommen wollen um ihn zu kommen
müssen wir es natürlich ein bisschen
schiiten ja das heißt in der nächsten
folge bei max werdet jetzt natürlich
sehen
da werden wir doch wahrscheinlich
irgendwie im game mode kurz gehen werden
uns die sachen holen
betrachten wir jetzt selbst nicht so
mega krass als chatten oder sowas ist
einfach ein schönes ende für so eine
folge für so ein projekt im end quasi zu
kämpfen dafür dass wir uns ist es in
ordnung wenn wir mal ganz kurz in den
game ja ich hoffe ihr seid da auch auf
unserer seite aber das wäre dann alles
auch in der nächsten folge bei maxim ich
würde sagen da wir jetzt nochmal hier
oben stehen max wir zeichnen uns noch
mal kurz gegenseitig alter ich finde das
so bescheuert weil ich die ganze zeit
nur so kann gucken ja ich auch mal zu
eigentlich immer dann inventar mit ich
mein mann inventar mit der zeit haben
wir noch wir haben noch aus abgedruckt
das jetzt mag es übrigens der hier steht
aber es gibt auch so scheiße aus ich
weiß ja was ganz spiegelverkehrt es aber
es sieht einfach überhaupt nicht so aus
wie das gerade eigentlich in
wirklichkeit aussieht aber damit würde
ich sagen haben wir den die
produktivität skala hier mal wieder
komplett unterbrochen wenn euch der tat
heute gefallen hat würden wir uns beide
war ein like von euch freuen die nächste
folge gemeinschaft und auch schon die
letzte folge von diesem projekt wird es
morgen auf max kanal geben wo wir dann
das ende besiegen werden bis ende gehen
werden und dort den ender drachen
besiegen werden hier findet ihr einen
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren um keine
videos mehr zu verpassen und hier findet
ihr ein weiteres video eingeblendet
einfach irgend eins also checkt es ab
und bis bald